[Aplausos]
vi las primeras luces de este mundo
mientras juan goytisolo recorría una
esquina de nuestra península el rincón
de los rincones el campo de níjar
leí campos de níjar con 14 o 15 años y
recuerdo que me causó una impresión muy
profunda y despertó en mí un deseo que
puede considerarse extravagante yo lo
que quería ser es nijareño
cosa que con el paso del tiempo y no sin
esfuerzo he conseguido gozosamente lo
que no podía imaginarme en aquel momento
era la importancia que va a tener
colitis solo en el desarrollo de mi
trayectoria profesional
tampoco podía imaginarme entonces por
inmadurez que una generación de
almeriense entre los que me cuento iba a
resultar absolutamente impactada por
esta mirada de goytisolo sobre nuestra
tierra
y no se me ocurre ninguna manera mejor
de referirme a ese impacto a esa
influencia que la toma de conciencia de
una condición moral del paisaje
esta reflexión moral está presente en la
obra de campos de níger pero sobre todo
el autor se refiere a ella a su
experiencia de viaje al proceso de
creación literaria como un momento de
tensión entre dos formas de miradas por
una parte sentía en sus propias palabras
un arrobo estético por la belleza
descarnada y descomunal del campo de
níjar y al mismo tiempo sentía una
indignación moral como consecuencia de
las malas condiciones de vida que tenían
los habitantes de la época esta dualidad
de la mirada venía también de una de las
propuestas de goytisolo de una de sus
enseñanzas nos hizo ver que nuestras
miradas sobre nuestro espacio de vida
cotidiano es una mirada crítica exigente
y rigurosa mientras que cuando viajamos
con motivo de una excursión o de un
viaje turístico esa mirada se vuelve
complaciente hedonista y lúdica
de esa cualidad de la mirada hemos
aprendido mucho en muchos paisajistas
tanto de la geografía como de otras
muchas disciplinas nos enseñó también
una cosa respecto a la mirada que aun
ultraperiférico como un almeriense le
resulta grata el proponía que la mirada
desde la periferia al centro siempre
superior a la que se produce desde el
centro a la periferia lo cual como
almeriense debe congratularnos porque
nuestras miradas siempre está en el
punto correcto
los que decidimos seguir a goytisolo en
su trayectoria literaria en su
producción intelectual y también con
cierta curiosidad en su evolución vital
aprendimos alguna otra cosa de cortisol
o aprendimos a mehdi near que hay una
manera de vagar sin rumbo sin objetivos
específicos por las calles de una ciudad
por el campo y aprendimos que eso nos
emparentaba con una tradición secular de
grandes paseantes lo que los franceses
se llaman los flanes aquino emparentaba
con baudelaire con hessel en berlín lo
emparentaba con walter benjamin con
guido board con susan sontag con una
serie de gente que había ido
descubriendo la mirada de un modo
itinerante de un modo nómada
y aprendimos muchas cosas más aprendimos
por ejemplo que hay que saber
diferenciar siempre lo que es una
propuesta literaria de lo que es un
producto editorial
cosa que él siguió a rajatabla porque
juan fue mucha casa pero sobre todo fue
un referente moral y aprendimos también
que la profesión del intelectual es una
profesión de riesgo
aprendimos que hay que buscar la belleza
de la dignidad y aprendimos que hay que
estar preparados para pagar las facturas
que te paguen qué te pasa la decisión de
ser independiente o de ser libre
la estela poderosa de juan goytisolo ha
desaparecido ya no está entre nosotros
pero sigue habiendo un faro potente en
el horizonte que no aconseja que debemos
seguir pensando en la condición moral
del paisaje esto es lo que me propongo
compartir con vosotros esta tarde
debo advertir que ahora viene una parte
de propuestas filosóficas si
estuviéramos en un avión el comandante
se dirigiría al pasaje y diría que se
hace con una zona de turbulencia por
favor permanezcan en sus asientos
abróchense los cinturones mientras
permanezca encendida la luz de aviso
durante mucho tiempo la comunidad
científica de pensadores filósofos
artistas intelectuales se han hecho una
pregunta muy básica respeto al paisaje
la pregunta es qué es el paisaje
bueno pues debo advertir que sea una
pregunta trampa porque esa pregunta te
obliga a pensar en el ser del paisaje y
te obliga a dar una respuesta que
inevitablemente es falsa porque el
paisaje no es
cuando estaba en la facultad mis
profesores de geografía se empeñaban en
hacerme ver que el paisaje eran las
cosas que veíamos luego con un silogismo
fatal de 100 si quieres conocer el
paisaje conoce las cosas o el
conocimiento del paisaje será una
consecuencia inevitable del conocimiento
de las cosas de las cosas que se vengan
pues
me rebelé contra esa propuesta de una
manera muy intuitiva porque yo tampoco
tenía demasiada madurez durante la
carrera pero aquello me restaba no me
resultaba un poco repugnante y decidí
inaugurar un camino
un poco particular un poco individual
fronterizo quizá marginal en ocasiones
pero que me ha resultado sumamente
revelador en vez de pensar en las cosas
como el paisaje empecé a pensar en la
mirada empecé a pensar en la percepción
empecé a pensar en representación en
significado en narrativa en obligaciones
morales y en su inevitable desembocadura
que es la capacidad movilizadora del
paisaje
intentaré explicarme
las cosas en los objetos los elementos
que forman las vistas o las escenas
tienen diversas cualidades o atributos
tienen una actualidad básica ontológica
que esas cosas si son el paisaje no es
pero las cosas que vemos si son una casa
es una casa un árbol es un árbol una
montaña es una montaña esa es su
cualidad ontológica luego tienen una
forma y una serie de atributos que nos
permiten distinguir los unos de otros
las cosas parecen ese parecer en su
condición fenomenológica las cosas por
otra parte pueden insinuar los sentidos
significados de ser su condición o su
cualidad semántica pero la pregunta que
debemos hacernos es cuál es la cualidad
paisajística de las cosas qué es lo que
hace que una cosa sea paisaje
la cualidad paisajística de las cosas es
que comparecen ante la mirada
es una definición sencilla pero que
requiere una cierta un cierto desarrollo
en primer lugar la mirada es fundamental
para el paisaje si apuramos el argumento
podemos decir que el paisaje existe si
hay una mirada si no hay mirada no hay
paisaje habrá cosas pero no paisaje
es decir la mirada funda el paisaje
pero luego tenemos el otro elemento no
tan sencillo de explicar como este de la
mirada el comparecer estamos
acostumbrados al uso lingüístico donde
perdón jurídico del término
comparecencia o legislativo político que
es que alguien llama a otra persona que
comparece en cumplimiento de una
obligación desde ese punto de vista es
la mirada la que obliga a las causas a
comparecer pero no es el sentido de
guardarle quiero remontarme en el
sentido etimológico del verbo comparecer
con parecer hace referencia a una
condición fenomenológica especial es
decir es un parecer pero un parecer
compartido
un parecer que requiere muchas miradas y
que requiere acuerdos culturales
las cosas comparecen ante la mirada si
existe esa posibilidad de acuerdo
cultural a la hora de apreciarla
valorarla
integrarlas dentro de ese conglomerado
cultural
el comparecer de las cosas ante la
mirada necesita una serie de universos
culturales compartidos que son los que
permiten por otra parte codificar los
signos de aquello que vemos de la efe
porque todos compartimos los repertorios
simbólicos una mochila que cada uno
llevamos que en parte viene de nuestras
capacidades de nuestra creatividad pero
en su mayor parte viene de un acervo
cultural común especialmente común desde
que los medios de comunicación de masas
han estandarizado y que casi todos
tenemos nuestra memoria las mismas
películas los mismos libros los mismos
discos al menos generacionalmente eso
afortunadamente eso va moviéndose no
pero bueno podemos llegar a decir que el
paisaje consiste como acción en capturar
esos signos que a través de nuestro
aparato sensorial con la vista en primer
término pero también con otros sentidos
y ponerlo en conexión con nuestra
conciencia y con nuestra memoria gráfica
simbólica que es lo que nos permite
asignarle significados y comprenderlos
desde ese punto de vista
del paisaje se parece mucho a las
lecturas cuando abrimos un libro no nos
entretenemos ver si la tipografía tiene
sherif o no tiene o si que elegantemente
acaba está efe lo que hacemos es leer
sílabas que forman palabras que abren
significados que tienen unas reglas
sintácticas gramaticales que nos
permiten acceder a pensamientos
sofisticados y de mando bien pues en el
paisaje de pasa exactamente igual
el paisaje es una lectura
esto es más metafórico hasta casi
disección esto es lo que es la práctica
del paisaje que esa lectura del paisaje
no es una ocurrencia mía ni es de ahora
un famoso tratadista hans blumenberg
en un libro que se llama la legibilidad
del mundo explica que desde la edad
media se utiliza una metafórica del
libro de la naturaleza está claro que la
edad media con una
un origen religioso y de una manera muy
poco sutil refiriéndose a como libro a
la biblia y que la naturaleza como dios
nos deje de panteísmo no pero bueno eso
era en la media es que luego las
metáforas sigue usándose en otras claves
hasta la modernidad más reciente en la
que un montón de analistas tienen que
recurrir a algo que podríamos llamar
algo así como la estructura lingüística
de nuestra comprensión del mundo
os pido solo que os fijéis en los
títulos de estos de estas obras que se
le finado aquí son fundamentales en
cualquier caso pero hay muchas más del
paisaje finalmente se configura como una
lectura de signos a la búsqueda del
significado el paisaje es una actitud de
la mirada el paisaje es un una acción un
acto paisaje es hacer
antes decía que el paisaje no es pero el
paisaje es hacer
el paisaje se hace cuando hacemos
paisaje generamos una representación
cultural que viene de nuestras
capacidades pero sobre todo de esto que
tenemos compartido con todos los que
componen nuestro tiempo y nuestra zona
cultural porque no hay que olvidar que
el paisaje se concibe de manera muy
distinta en distintas
en regiones civilizaciones esculturas y
demás
necesitamos como hemos dicho un universo
cultural compartido para que las cosas
comparezcan ante la mirada de ese
universo cultural compartido no es
estático podemos enriquecer los cómo se
enriquece ese universo pues aportando
nuevos significados aportando
creatividad para que la mirada tenga un
arsenal nuevo en la mochila y pueda
generar representaciones culturales
distintas
adquirimos conciencia del paisaje cuando
adoptamos una posición activa o
respectiva en todo caso exigente ante la
apertura hermética es decir la apertura
de los significados
voy a intentar ponerlo algunos ejemplos
bueno imaginaos que va hay un día por un
itinerario que hacéis muy habitualmente
de casa al trabajo por ejemplo y podéis
ir andando o en coche o en un transporte
colectivo o lo que sea en un paisaje ya
tan rutinario lo habéis leído tantas
veces que no le prestan mucha atención
si acaso si hay algún elemento nuevo por
observar para incorporarlo a esas
certezas que necesitamos en nuestros
desplazamientos cotidianos pero un día
os acompaña alguien una amiga un amigo
que de pronto dice oye rodolfo ha visto
que aquella montaña que hay allí se
parece al perfil de un rostro humano
entonces lo mira y dice anda pues no me
había dado cuenta es verdad
en ese momento se desencadenan dos
mecanismos sencillos pero muy poderosos
el primero de ellos trae como
consecuencia que no podrás mirar esa
montaña sin ver el rostro humano y el
segundo no menos importante que
recordarás a quién te dijo que aquello
parecía un rostro humano
esto es el mecanismo de la connotación
el mecanismo básico por el que hay una
transmisión cultural que nos permite
interferir en la mirada del otro
este es un mecanismo de connotación muy
sencillo y evidentemente se pueden
sofisticadas hasta el nivel que queramos
el poeta chileno raúl zurita decía en
una frase de una precisión quirúrgica
que el poema en lo que media entre la
pasión y el paisaje
nos emplazaba una propuesta que se
emparenta con la clásica de hölderlin de
que habitamos poéticamente el mundo no
sea en clave poética en narrativa lírica
gráfica plástica o musical cualquier
propuesta artística interfiere en tu
mirada y la enriquece
no es lo mismo pasear por mi querido
valle de rodalquilar si has leído no hay
nada estado de carmen de burgos que si
no lo he leído
no es lo mismo visitar barcelona si has
leído la ciudad de los prodigios' de
eduardo mendoza que si no lo he leído
no es lo mismo comprender cualquier
ciudad del mundo si has tenido la
ocasión gozosa de la ciudad de
invisibles de italo calvino o si no has
tenido esa ocasión
tu mirada sobre eso ha hecho que
objetivamente son los mismos cambia
radicalmente
hablando de ciudades
walter benjamin el que citaba ante como
un ilustre paseante decía que perderse
uno en una ciudad como se pierde uno en
un bosque requiere toda una educación
es una frase interesante que además wiki
sólo le ha gustado mucho porque la
repetía con frecuencia
la cuestión es que las ciudades son
realmente bosques son bosques semánticas
son difíciles de transitar de comprender
tienen una acumulación significa
múltiples niveles de lectura y
seguramente los senderos que se
necesitan para circular por el bosque
son senderos que muy bien pueden ser
narrativos o de cualquier otra
disciplina artística pero voy a proponer
los narrativos por qué
os voy a dar tres ejemplos de cómo
intentó explicar la ciudad de almería a
la gente que me acompaña las excursiones
espontáneas o regladas que hago
el primero de ellos es que almería es
una ciudad caníbal que se come a sí
misma
podéis imaginar la apertura de
significados que se abren a partir de
eso y de explicar la ciudad en esa clave
o que almería en una ciudad a la fuga
seguramente huyó porque se va comiendo
aunque almería una ciudad defensiva que
ha estado sometida a múltiples asedios
bombardeos los peores hechos por
nosotros mismos o que almería en una
ciudad compleja pero que se puede buscar
el detalle la plástica la riqueza la
sutileza de composiciones sencillas de
volúmenes directos
el paisaje contiene una promesa
qué es la de la búsqueda de la cohesión
de las sociales la posibilidad de
establecer relatos discursos comunes en
estos tiempos de polarización de
alteridad de vanidad de individuos
individuales desbordantes el paisaje nos
recuerda también que nuestra forma de
vida mediterránea es una forma de vida
que tiene una habilidad especial para
connotar los paisajes los sitios en
clave lúdica y en clave colectiva
debilitar esa conciencia mediterránea no
empobrece y nos hace vulnerables
el paisaje es el último patrimonio
posible
el paisaje un espacio de libertad y de
compromiso es una biblioteca abierta las
24 horas del día
lo último que me queda para que mi
intervención es animarlos a que cuando
salgamos de esta sala
hagamos paisaje miremos de una manera
activa interrogante que participemos en
la creación de nuevos significados de
nuestra ciudad de nuevas connotaciones
que practiquemos la generosidad del
paseo compartido que intentemos juntar
un proyecto ambicioso común a partir de
nuestras miradas y de compartir los
valores que cada una de ellas trae en
definitiva que reconozcamos la dimensión
moral del paisaje y que habitamos
poéticamente el mundo
[Aplausos]